Sometimes when we code we have a typo.
Or we forget the variable name
that we defined earlier, and
we just had to trace back and
use the console as a clue for us to go
back and figure out what's going on.
>> And so,
to avoid problems like these too,
it's helpful to have a text
editor that works with you.
So Sublime Text for instance,
comes with a tab completion by default.
That tab completion will use variable
names that you've used already to help
you out.
So definitely using all the tools at
your disposal is very, very helpful.
>> So, I'll show you my auto completion,
I'm adding bio, bio's my object.
I hit a dot, and here you go.
And bio pic, I hit tab and then done.
So it's very useful and
it's worth the time and
effort to learn a good text editor.
It could be any text editor, but
just make sure that this text
editor has these capabilities
that will allow programmers and
developers to quickly and
efficiently program.
Such as Sublime Text, Atom, what
other text editors do you recommend?
>> I use Vim, so
if you're willing to learn Vim,
it's a bit of a steep learning curve,
but rewarding.
>> It is rewarding.
And also, if you're old school,
you could use another type of
text editor, called Emacs.
[LAUGH] Right, so there's there's
a lot of great, and free,
text editors out there.
I just recommend, just pick one and
stick with it and
learn how to use the tools
that these editors come with.
>> Yeah, because as a programmer you're
going to be spending hours of your day,
every day, using it.
So it helps to actually like
the program that you're using.
>> And you can use the w3.org
validator for CSS.
But something really cool that we,
here, at Udacity found was
the csslint.net,
which is very cool in detecting errors.
And so, this is how the website looks,
csslint.net.
And this is where you paste your code,
CSS code here.
And, so you can pick and
choose which errors and
warnings you want to test for a below.
So I would say,
you can pick everything that is there
in our Udacity style-guide rules.
And you can see if they match
with one of these errors and
enable only those errors and
run your code through it.
So, I have a very basic sample
of CSS code right here,
that I'm just going to run it through.
So, I just enabled all the errors here,
just to look at how I've been coding,
and what are the best practices,
and just what errors it catches.
So, I'm just going to go ahead and
run the linter.
So it says CSS lint found one errors and
zero warnings, so
let's see what this is.
It says there is a parsing error expected
RBRACE at line three column eight.
So it's pointing me to right here.
>> So it looks like you're
missing a semicolon at the end
of the font family rule.
>> My god, yes,
I am indeed missing that.
Ok, so let's go back and
add a semicolon here.
Yeah, these errors can be very frustrating.
I never catch them in time.
Okay, so now it says CSS lint found
zero errors and zero warnings.
So yeah, here,
looks like my code is clean now and
I also checked it through CSS Lint,
done now.
When you have a huge block of JSON
data just sitting inside one file and
you are passing that data to display
render it in order
paste it to our web page and so on.
It can happen that yeah,
it might have a lot of errors in it,
or you might be missing a comma or
a curly brace.
And then curly brace,
which always happens to me.
We actually have something
called JSONLint.
JSONLint helps you
validate your JSON data.
So I'm going to share my screen with
you, and take you to jsonlint.com.
And so here,
on jsonlint.com you can see that I've
pasted a very small bit of JSON data.
This is basically my bio object
which you will be working on, and
your resume created various objects for
bio, work and education.
I can come back to that,
I'm drifting over here, from the topic.
But yeah, so I have this JSON data
pasted inside the JSON validator.
Now I'll let it validate, and
I see that I have an error.
Here, under result,
it says parse error on line one.
And it says varbio equals this.
I think we have to separate
the variable from the object name.
[LAUGH] We're just very
glad I found out, so
I'm going to take just this page
right here, and then hit validate.
[INAUDIBLE] I think they don't
define object names inside
your JSON Validator.
So one can just give the JSON data
without assigning it to an object.
And then that will just validate it
>> Yeah,
I think that's what I
was doing wrong here.
So, JSON objects,
don't put in the object name.
>> Yeah, we can try that,
we can even try [CROSSTALK].
>> It's still a.
It's just the object,
no var no name for object.
So it looks like this block is valid.
It's a valid JSON file.
It looks like my nesting is perfect.
I have my name, I have my rule.
My contacts has three
separate attributes, as well,
the mobile, email, and location.
So I can enclose it
with the curly braces.
And then my skills are an array,
so I define it as an array and
that way I have the square braces there.
>> Awesome.
>> Definitely.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] Okay,
so this is jsonlint.com.
Whenever you find yourself getting
stuck being able to access JSON data,
just ensure that
the structure is valid before
you use that data inside
functions to render it.
So, just like usual, I get small snippets
to make sure I validate something.
>> It can get crazy when you have
a large amount of data that seems just
like one JSON file, [INAUDIBLE] the data,
so it helps to validate those.